[Musik]
shakira weil meine haare immer noch
gestreift sind es hallo leute ich ist
wieder einmal wanne und willkommen zu
einem neuen paar video richtig originell
hier wieder am start ich will ehrlich
mit euch sein diese ganze hand werbungs
reise war super aufregend und klasse
klicks sind reingekommen aber jetzt ist
es doch zeit mich mal für irgendwas zu
entscheiden denn ich finde sind wir mal
ehrlich das ist nix seid ihr euch
wundert über meine wimpern die sind über
nacht gewachsen und dann kam mir gestern
natürlich wieder die beste idee aller
zeiten
es gibt nämlich gerade auf youtube so
ein trend er nennt sich carsten in front
of me the water i die person vor mir
entscheidet was ich esse und dann fahren
die leute durch den drei für und sagen
einfach ich hätte gerne das was die
person vorher bestellt hat und weil ich
nicht umsonst trentmann heiße dachte ich
mir es wäre eine lustige idee wenn ich
meinen friseur anrufe in frage was er
dem letzten kunden davor gefärbt hat und
dann das gleiche bestelle mehr russisch
roulette kann es für meine haarfarbe
nicht geben
[Musik]
denn mein friseur ist kohle riss und er
fährt jeden tag einfach alle ich sage
jetzt schon mal ich hoffe das ist nicht
blond wird ich bin nämlich gerade dabei
mein blond raus wachsen zu lassen und
dachte mir so ok jetzt ist erstmal gut
so wir haben alle gelacht die haare sind
kaputt arbeit ist erstmal gut nur wenn
er jetzt gleich sagt ja ich habe
komplett platinblond blondiert ich weiß
nicht was mir an merkt aber ich bin sehr
sehr aufgeregt
falls sie jetzt auch gerade parallel auf
instagram unterwegs seid folgt ihm gerne
auf instagram tommy mommsen heißt er da
ist ein super typ macht sehr lustige
story es lohnt sich auf jeden fall okay
jetzt entscheidet sich was meine nächste
haarfarbe sein wird ich hoffe er kann
gerade rangehen
ich muss jetzt ein bisschen später noch
mal probieren ich habe mir ein tag für
mich immer leben irgendwann später so
kam ich vor 10 minuten angerufen ich
hoffe erstmal zurück ach mir geht es
ganz gut
ich schwimme den millionen das buch
verkauft sich super klasse per ok was
hast du deiner letzten kunden gefärbt
was die komplette tour ist geplant
ich hoffe das ist nicht blond wird ich
möchte genau drei grad ein video und es
gibt auf youtube grazer ein trend ich
esse das was man ein der kunde vor mir
quasi gestellt hat
[Musik]
ich habe auch die ganze gedacht oh gott
ich kann ja nichts ist russisch roulette
ich kann nichts beeinflussen strawberry
blond okay das heißt aber wir müssen
wieder heller gehen alles klar
wenn s bahn wollte gestern als idee hat
er anrufen da hätte ich blau grün
bekommen
okay vielleicht doch ich war gerade erst
so schön dunkel und jetzt geht es wieder
weg zu blond ja gut dann schalten wir
jetzt mal zu dienstag
ich bin jetzt wie tommy und wir machen
jetzt meine haare machen wir mal ganz
kurz mit historie zu wissen was passiert
was ist nicht passiert also du warst ja
damals da was damals war sie noch blond
so spricht ganz ganz unten ist noch
dieses blog von früher
danach haben wir angefangen die dunkel
zu töten und dann das war's genau aber
ich weiß nicht warum also in der mitte
ist halt wer also den dunkler streifen
und oben ist aber voll hängen ich dachte
immer dass wir nur eine tönung drauf
gemacht haben wie er das haar trotzdem
irgendwie heller gezogen da durch den
okzident rückt als vier prozent leben
weiterleben lassen so viele haben ein
schönes vorher so
[Musik]
also der thommy der färbt mir jetzt
entfernt liegt mir jetzt hinten die
haare was sagst du meinen haaren was das
heißt wohl gefühlt ich habe tatsächlich
ausnahmsweise mal ein gutes gefühl hier
ok nein es bleibt spannend das ding ist
das einzige problemchen ist ja einfach
nur dieser dunkle fleck weißt du deshalb
arbeite ich jetzt einfach von diesen
dunklen fleck aufgabe macht jetzt
fordern blauen trikots strawberry
wassersuppe karls erdbeerhof
[Musik]
kein us-präsident ist krebs wassenberg
krebs typisch für jemanden mit dem assen
lance krebs ist freundlich zuvorkommend
und schnell begeistert von etwas zu sein
aber dann plötzlich einen rückzieher zu
machen
absolut ich absolut ich bin immer wie
die dann sagen sie ja dann fahren wir
alle auf das festival und wenn alle
buchen dann sah ich bin noch nicht aber
egal ob es sich um ein geschäft oder
eine bombe handelt in die sache wird
erstmal verschoben 800.000 so und jetzt
bist du dran
wann ist ein geburtstag ist wassermann
leicht so immer am puls der zeit ja ihr
sogar voraus zu sein
auf jeden fall immer zu wissen was
gerade in ist mary plan würde ich aber
auch sagen 'du weißt echt mal was in das
spiel zu den schwachpunkten ist käuflich
das ist echt schön wenn wir wenn ich
dann das gespräch vorher denken thorsten
thorn die machst du wenn du landest du
willst ja das alles ungefähr gleich
blondiert ist ja du fängst habe auf
einer seite fängst du an
ja wir können ja mal wenn du willst und
drehen ohne hier alles hinzuschmeißen
und dann mache ich das doch einfach mal
auch und kokereien und sehe h hier ist
auf jeden fall schon was l und da mache
ich sie dazu und cook am besten mal auf
die uhr
aha das ist um 10 uhr dann gucke ich
vielleicht und 14.10 noch mal war ich
hasse es wenn man einschläft bach auf
tschuldigung so das weiß was wir immer
machen können du kannst mir einmal die
haare färben
das war so lustig wird dir sagen du
musst das noch so und so machen sich
erst einmal und dann muss ich es machen
und dann machst du hast und dann drehe
ich dir den kopf ab wir spielen friseur
azubi prüfung war es dann auch nur 45
minuten zeit
nein
[Musik]
doch 2 ich sehe aus bei müllers hat die
brandanschläge landrat da kam ein solid
verschüttet und sich nicht auf letztlich
wissen wir in den dreck tracks recht
warm einnahmen weg weg weg 321 pinsel
vom kopf jetzt müssen wir das auswaschen
und tommy möchte steffen hallo wo sind
die assistenten wenn man sie braucht er
so lustig wenn jetzt alle meine haare
einfach ausfallen so was geht nicht ich
weiß auch nicht wo man so nur videos her
bekommen also ich glaube das sind dann
zu sprechen oder so steil richtig super
bowl finale gekommen trainerstunden aber
auch er ab und fährt kann das sein dass
sich immer noch diese scheiße von dem
handwerkszeug rieche so für immer wenn
meine haare feucht werden richtig noch
so ein und zwar zum 1
canon speak to the manager machst du da
machst du deine pflege rein kommen jetzt
hier sieht man schon mal das contour
auch schön
dann tönt
[Musik]
ok
also das ja nicht das 1 1 robert lentner
wie die dame aber auf jeden fall gleich
ist nicht gleich treatment ich sehr
offen palina rojinski mit bella womit
wofür macht sich noch mit partie
probleme oder bella
einlagen
[Musik]
jetzt bin ich auf jeden fall erstmal
strawberry super
[Musik]
[Gelächter]